we're gonna do uh quick intros for
sophia and genevieve um i would like to
first start by just saying my
association um
with these two gals are you guys okay
with the word gal is that cancelled um
actually i'm i have to go do you mind if
i say last time
by the way
by the way the bit you just did storming
out was completely overshadowed by how
incredibly flexibly well you did it
and the comedy went away and i just got
impressed oh yeah i i was like i guess
there's no way to walk out without
ruining your whole studio
you literally just like like
shape-shifted like gumby through a tiny
space is this what happens when you have
to escape russia you get really good at
getting out of small spaces there's a
tiny hole in the border
russian women can get through really
tiny spaces really quickly you know i
have that joke in my act about how you
know my biggest dream growing up there
was uh to grow up and be a beautiful and
tiny woman that can fit inside a tinier
woman
so your dream is
exactly right in the materials
when i first started doing it
without the body movements they're like
wait what but then as soon as i started
making myself
because they were like yes because
that's what the russian nesting doll is
called yes is it safe to say that you're
both russian ukrainian what would i call
it what is that correct
they're
i've never look how scary they are
i'm just certain
there's a very big difference between
like american women and russian
ukrainian women uh
there's a
i wouldn't say assertive it's just a
not codependent
it's a look how they're not even
blinking they're like i don't even know
i don't know what was happening like i'm
i don't try i'm i'm sweating i'm
terrified where do you see yourself in
five years i just don't know i mean in
whatever way
wherever you want
in a bigger version of myself in your
closet
so just context really quick genevieve
is a very very close friend of mine also
my my liberty trainer of my horse so
when you guys see me on instagram doing
magical things with my horse that looks
like it's like animated and photoshopped
and it is because of the relationship i
built with that horse thanks to
genevieve um she is a master of all
things um confidence clear communication
uh
boundaries boundaries
uh look how many boundaries she sets by
just sitting there i don't know how not
to have them yeah it's like it's i'll
show you i'll show you i want to be
genevieve when i grow up and she's the
most self-possessed person i've known
her for like three minutes i'm like yeah
it is so wild just wearing a blazer in
converse like it's nothing like it's
just it's and
and we've been i've known you for what
six years now just about i think about
six years and um
i admire you i look up to you i don't
know that much about your background i'm
excited to learn about it today um okay
so uh just for context sophia i'm a fan
of comedian uh who's incredible i was
trying to put together a podcast that
basically was look
we are grown ass adults and there's a
war happening and as you can tell by the
fact that i'm wearing glasses on the
podcast today we're talking about
serious shit
it's the one time i've fucking failed
the one in the last two years of this
podcast the one time i could actually
find my glasses happens to be when we're
talking about war you also want brunette
for this correction
for this
we can't really talk about like russian
ukraine war international conflicts if i
look like courtney love it just feels
insulting to everyone but i just want to
be clear i just again the the point of
this podcast is like but you know uh
school is always in session we're always
learning we're always growing you know
take what you like leave the rest god
grant me the strategy they accept the
things i cannot change the courage to
change the things that i can and the
wisdom to know the difference i'm not
saying you're gonna listen this episode
and you're going to be lectured about
how to fix the war there's you can't we
can't there's we'll talk about later
things we can do if um
uh uh just the way that we live our
lives and the choices we make but i just
really wanted to as someone that was
raised in the united states and i wanted
to express all the stereotypes that i
was programmed with about russia ukraine
the ignorance that is in my heart
and i would love to know what it was
like growing up there
versus here and just start to understand
because when i think russia i'm like
mail order brides emily don't get any
ideas
the only way emily and i will ever get a
husband are they taking them in the
reverse i was gonna lead with that
because we've also been we've been
programmed to hate the only way we are
related to we're either sex objects
right
or we're evil
or you have the election we you have the
election like i've noticed in the past
like four years when i get an uber or a
cab and i notice that someone's russian
everyone on this podcast knows how
obsessed with russia i am um uh if i'm
like oh hey where are you from
and if they're russian they'll kind of
like be embarrassed or ashamed or like
think i'm gonna be mad at them for like
rigging the election you know what i
mean um
so uh and i've talked many times on the
podcast about how vladimir putin like a
lot of people over there believe that
he's got doubles that have had plastic
surgery to look like him just like sort
of growing up in a place where you never
know what's true or false you never have
and that's never even been on the table
and as an american going oh in the last
couple years the idea of fake news just
hit us but this is something that's been
in your lives forever you guys have to
stop me from talking okay you have to
interrupt me all right i will keep going
let me go ahead and unless i know about
something the more i'll talk about it
wonderful let me just go ahead and talk
about myself because i know that topic i
know yes i see those are the boundaries
okay stop
let me let me talk um
well first of all uh i am
i am ukrainian i'm from odessa you're
from odessa what are the fucking chances
right my mom was born in odessa my
biological father who's now in czech
republic was also born in odessa and
those are the two parts of me is my mom
is russian
we thought just korean found out next to
23andme that she's actually korean
japanese great-grandma mm-hmm um and my
father is ukrainian thought he was just
ukrainian he's actually ukrainian uh and
par romanian gypsy so and then you came
uh to america when and why
we came to moscow first because my my
mom remarried my stepdad it was not is
an awesome really cool
uh
engineer but he does he's too smart i
don't understand how smart he is
right right but he also gave me a lot of
insight because he went he was like in
the army for six years he was he was
some sort of lieutenant or something
like that and he went there in moscow
um and he also was on the aviation unit
he never was actually in battle or
anything like that yeah but um
he did you know he went through that and
he had the experience was this the
russian military
well it was a soviet union back one okay
okay so soviet union was from seven
from 1917 until 1991.
dumb question what is the difference
between the soviet union and now russia
so the ussr is uh was
essentially a land grab that made um
slavic countries
all united under the banner of the ussr
so
is gigantic um russia is also big so i
think people in their head are like it's
the same 100 but actually ukraine is you
know uh one-fourth about the size of
russia yeah so it would be like if the
united states if like the ussr if there
was a uh
you know a carbon copy over here it
would be like like if america
was russia and then the ussr would be
like
our version america
just like alaska canada america right
yeah central america totally and then
canada i'm sorry
uh ukraine would be like mexico yes kind
of thing yes and that was all one
country under communist and then you
know and every and and lithuania and
latvia and all the other slavic
countries so um
that is
one of the things that the independence
thing
for ukraine brings up and the reason
that so many people in in the former
ussr are so like into
and invested is because
um
it's not like countries wanted to just
give up their culture and their language
to become part of the ussr and they they
weren't asked to that's the thing it's
not a it wasn't a question right right
well that was before like the internet
when you could just do whatever the fuck
you wanted and conquer anywhere and maps
weren't even right like like that we
have
like two things like i'm big on like
cartography is not even real like how do
we even know all this is right like it
was so much easier to control millions
and millions of people in masses because
whoever controlled the newspapers like
that's who got to decide what the truth
was you know so now we're in this place
where we're we're kind of still there
though
right in russia we're still there yeah
that's the shocking part is like
some who are these magicians they're
able to just like take this internet
that we don't even we can't even fathom
right and then they're like okay not
this not that not this
and here is your window into the world
and in this window i'm putin's like the
lisa frank you know what i mean he's
just like unicorns and butterflies
and
people are like oh yeah yeah we know
this person like this is how we know him
right because he has been able to
manipulate everybody's perception of him
which i want to get to in a second but
let's just go when did you come to the
states and then uh uh sophia yes and
just and why like just right sorry can i
ask a dumb question and we might cut
this out
no i don't look dumb but um everyone
should look dumb i'm trying my very hard
to be dumb publicly i it's just we won't
learn so if your families are both from
odessa and at one point odessa was part
of the ussr as part of ukraine do you
consider yourselves russian or ukrainian
and this is why yes both this is why
it's such a complicated question it
depends on who you're talking to exactly
okay some people will vehemently be like
no i am ukrainian and that's really a
big part of their identity which is
again why this invasion is really fucked
up and why can you elaborate on that
yeah because uh
russia
has
when when ukraine was part of ussr
ukraine existed all of these things
pre-existed all these countries
pre-existed before ussr absolutely can i
just get okay this is what i need and i
think for like i don't mean average as
in the average person but just the
person that doesn't have time to do all
this research why are they both drinking
at the same time is that an odessa thing
is that what can you give me
a metaphor for what this is like
as like like it's not about ukrainian
russia this would be like if america
invaded hawaii that's not it but like
what is the closest thing that a dumb
american uh if there's an equivalent if
there's an equivalent i mean i think
we've already done it with puerto rico
okay okay okay
it's kind of
not not exactly but
similar
it's kind of like that but on a timeline
i would say it's a little bit like we
know that
uh historically california was actually
part of mexico right
so
russia has as much acclaim to ukraine as
mexico would have to california all of a
sudden mexican president stands up and
goes all right california is our land
i'm going to brainwash everybody to
remind them that california is our land
why are they even speaking english over
there we have a large population of
hispanic people in california that would
be mind-blowingly
wild so people in odessa like in 1930
right like
in the soviet union right
would it consider did it was it a mix
did they consider themselves russian
then or do they consider sounds
ukrainian then or was it like russians
came to ukraine and then like and then
it was like all about
i can speak to that so
they would have considered the some
soviet because there was so much of that
brainwashing right so even there was uh
ukraine is also very much regionally
occupied okay and that's where you run
into the problem we have today okay
because this is gonna blow your mind too
it used to be poland
right western ukraine used to be poland
before that i was part of lithuania
right and ukrainian and polish are
actually really similar exactly
countries have been transitioning way
before kids in l.a
okay got it
yes got it yes
and each one of those
oh every each time a country overtook it
they push their own agenda and so when
when
uh but but ukraine was always there
those those ukrainian populations have
always been there
to just
just
picture this
kiev which is where they're fighting
right now yeah has been around the first
mention of it was 500 a.d
they already had monasteries there and
the first mention of it was done by the
vikings who actually were able to write
it down right but they already came to
that land knowing that there was kiev
there right you know where what
moscow was nothing literally so so
ukraine existed way before a lot of
modern-day russia's and now they're
trying to claim it as if it was there
and they had their own language they had
their own identity exactly to speak to
the soviet thing so
yeah you grow up brainwashed think like
taught that like no
the power that we all have is that we're
all one country despite of all of these
different countries despite all the
latvians the lithuanians the ukrainians
actually we're all soviet and who
started that stalin like who started
that idea
people always love to say communism or
socialism works in theory i'm like bitch
it's the same for capitalism isn't it
working out so yeah yeah yeah people all
over the world are right throwing
themselves out of a factory window
making fucking the this phone that i
have on me right now totally no
capitalism communism or the same not
working right right right same thing
i think that a lot of things probably we
uh were not able to see the cracks and
flaws before because there was no way to
corroborate because before the internet
and before being able to share
information like this like you didn't
even know it was something your truth
was what the five people in your town
told you was the truth or not just that
like i think the way that we have
propaganda you guys do too
so like americans had always been
programmed to be like they are shittier
than you they live in a cold shitty
place that is very poor
all they do is drink and they're very
sad i'm gonna
so speaking to that if i can add to that
it's actually even weirder which is i
was like this is a
it's a candy land of drunk people like
the architecture of russia that we have
been shown
it looks like a chocolate christmas
village because you only see one
building
it looks like disneyland the photos that
were in my history books of russia
made it look like a beautiful candy land
it looked like willy wonka's chocolate
factory you know what i'm saying and
like uh like everyone likes like in
their like cute hats and then you have
the nesting dolls you're like dude
they're they seem to be having a blast
over there
i'm saying but then they had the gall to
beat us in sports in the olympics so we
hate them you know so that's the other
thing is you grow up and
i would love to talk about russia's you
know relationship to the olympics
because it's like that's a huge obvious
the ego and the sports and the bravado
and the the machismo like that's
important to talk about but it's also
it's like they fucking
we beat them in hockey like beating them
in hockey was like if they beat us in
hockey we hate them and like i grew up
watching
men watch the olympics and go fuck
russia and imagine if they'd gotten to
the moon first
yeah thank god stanley kubrick got there
first
sorry can i ask one more question did
ukraine lose its cult did those did the
separate countries
lose their culture and identity during
the ussr because you have them but for
example they could like the de facto
language
right everywhere but i believe romania
was
russia russian okay so it's like were
they not teaching ukrainian in schools
they were
they were okay but yeah it was taught as
the second language until correct ussr
broke up and then it switched and then
ukrainians started being taught more
much more widely to me it feels like
it's like you know i just i love a good
like simple metaphor
for a simple break it's like
being married like marrying a god your
college sweetheart
having a little bit of stockholm
syndrome realizing the guy's kind of an
asshole and just wanted to control you
and then you decide you know what i'm
going to go live my own life i'm going
to divorce this guy i've been with for
you know 15 years at 30. we met when i
was in high school and i'm like
developing my identity i'm going and he
just won't stop like texting at 2am and
just like being like
you know
my name's still on your car insurance
what are you gonna do about like it just
won't let you move the fuck on and it's
like if i can't have you no one can
except he also has your credit card yep
and that's the thing right he has your
credit card he has your parents numbers
and he also has like those little green
cameras on you and he can cut off all of
your bills yes because they're set up
through him
so
amazon account netflix and just it also
doesn't even really want you back just
doesn't want you to be happy with anyone
else does want you back but what does he
want from you what is it what can you
crane besides the idea is the
pearl of the black sea
every every part that he's trying to get
is juicy yeah like he's trying to take
the juicy part he's not being like let
me into south dakota mm-hmm right he's
coming
i want california
florida i want new york gimme and it's
like uh no
what motivated you to come when did you
come what were the circumstances sofia
um so we moved um in 94 and it was just
me and my mom
and then
two years later my grandparents my mom's
sister and my cousin came over
um
we came to la because
um
my grandfather's sister and like her
whole family
um moved here in the 80s okay so can i
ask why yeah because they were like this
isn't great yeah we should go and so
they did and i mean a lot of jews left
and the jews left in the 90s and what's
the difference between someone that
wants to leave and someone that leaves
is it hard to leave is it easy to leave
it's very hard to leave they don't want
you to go the only way that we could
come over
then is like the way that the refugee
like we came over as jewish refugees the
way that that works is like um or worked
during that time is you can only come if
someone um directly related to you is
already there wow so that means the only
way we could come is because my grandpa
is related directly to his sister who is
here
so if she didn't come in the 80s
we would not have been able to come over
because we don't have that connection
the idea of like
pre-internet having like some kind of
like
like moscow city hall you had to do this
kind of paperwork in just sounds like a
nightmare yeah yeah it's it's it's very
crazy and like i don't know if you guys
did this but like we kept it incredibly
hush hush did you tell anybody you were
moving yeah we didn't tell my intentions
are totally different yeah it was so
different it was like even when you're
applying for the stuff it's like no you
don't tell anybody you don't tell
anybody you don't know if it's gonna
work you don't know if people are gonna
like something's gonna happen and you
won't be able to leave like you know i'm
11 years old and i'm like you can't tell
anybody you're leaving until and then
it's like right before we leave like the
last month or something or last couple
weeks then it's like yeah now you can
tell your friends and stuff and then do
you have a did your parents have jobs
lined up here already can you just come
here without a game plan
yeah there's so the reason we came is
like so my mom
um
she
both of my parents were
software engineers
so or computer engineers then my mom
started doing software so she's worked
in computers forever since i was a baby
since they were like those weird
scantron bullshit things um
and she and my father um
i've i've never met my dad he's seen me
twice
once when i was a baby and then once
when we were leaving and he's in russia
he is now in germany with like his
family
whatever i guess
he doesn't we don't fuck with each other
yeah yeah
is the answer to that but uh yeah anyway
he and my mom thanks for the comedy
career dad i know right i'm like my
merch is my daddy issues hopefully let's
say daddy and if she's here i'm like
thanks that's the best merch of all time
that's amazing
but yeah so we came because like my mom
for example she was so when you when you
go to school in in like a communist
country that there's no like
valedictorian salutatorian but you get
like medals because you love medals yeah
that's so so like gold medals in the red
diplom
the diploma colored is just is a big
thing and if it's red if it's you know
the communist color like you did amazing
yeah yeah so like my mom graduated with
a silver medal meaning like she was the
second best
student in her
class or whatever and um so one of the
great things about
communism is education is free yeah
and that is one of the biggest like in
cuba the literacy rate in cuba is 98
literacy rate and the biggest biggest
mistakes america's ever made is making
education a for-profit business yeah and
this is
a huge reason why so much stuff is going
wrong yeah but anyway my mom wanted to
go to medical school my grandma was a
doctor um and wow because my
we're jewish they didn't let her in
it's not like you get rejected and they
send you a letter and they're like so
sorry you know our admittance rate was
20
and your sat score didn't qualify no you
just don't get to go because you're
jewish it's not like there's not really
an explanation there's no like you can't
take it up with someone right right it's
not like that so my mom was like okay
well i had to do another career that i
didn't really want to do but like she
loves it she fell in love with it and so
things were really like hard me and her
lived in a communal apartment
um people don't here don't know what
that is but komanalki is
is like what they do is they take one
what would be here like say a one
bedroom apartment
and they move in two families into one
into each room and then the families
don't know each other this feels like a
netflix reality dating show that i would
watch yes
it's like a shitty two families in one
room you know what's interesting is
there is now a trend for these kind of
live in spaces and and when i
first understood this trend i was like
wait they're they're trying to bring
commonality to the states what's that
no it was like this is wild they're like
we work i'm like
this is yeah this is where we run away
from we don't like sharing space so can
i ask you what like when you what is the
what was the biggest culture shock when
you came to america the biggest like
different i mean of course you grew up
on american shows and stuff like that or
saw them or knew something like but like
what is the biggest like a couple of the
biggest like
like when i was in scare my living
situation and i think that'll help so
like okay what it was like living in the
komanalka right so um
you share the kitchen in the bathroom
with a different family another
different so the person that was living
in the room right next to ours and the
rooms by the way are like and by the way
is there what is the russian ukrainian
middle class situation at this time is
this like the the common living
conditions for most people we don't have
a middle
it's very hard it's like putin's got 400
billion dollars and then everyone else
lives like this yes yes that's important
to understand yes oligarchy and then
everybody else exactly
yeah the middle class is like really
really low there's there's no people
going like why don't you just get your
own apartment it's just this is how most
people here i'll explain about getting
your own apartment if you live in a
communist country so i think like again
you you guys truly don't understand
so first off the man we lived with was a
an old alcoholic man sure and i would
constantly so far we have the same
childhood so
well i would come home and i would be
like you know seven walking myself home
from school i would come and he would be
passed out in his piss and vomit at the
front of our front door and i have to
literally step over his body to open it
then i'd go into my room and lock the
door from the inside and that is how i
lived and that is just common and
there's want authority to
like make sure that move you have to put
an ad in the paper and you say
i i'm living in uh i'm seven yeah yeah
you're like i'm in silver lake i have
a one communal room that i share here on
the third floor um i am looking for one
room in this area that is blah blah or
if you're getting married you go putting
an ad um one room in this area one room
in this area trading for an apartment
with two rooms so then you find someone
else who's looking for the opposite
thing from you and you trade
that is how you move when i found out
people in america just move
yeah
[Music]
i was like for what people are going oh
yeah when i came into my friend's like
house american friend's house for the
first time they're like oh yeah don't
use that guest bathroom that's the guest
bathroom you said oh no that's actually
my daughter's bathroom i'm like
you're like that bathroom is not
someone's bedroom
it was fucked i was like are you all
just like making sure you like pee and
poop in different toilets like why all
the different bathrooms it's just the
luxury of this stuff is mind-blowing i'm
gonna even bring it down why are there
toilets because we had holes
we we had holes in and no doors
in in
serious in my first school
when you go as a young girl when you go
to the bathroom
you walk into an open space
with sinks and holes
and the whole little uh metal things for
your feet on the sides that have like
little metal spacers they don't slip
there's no doubt
there's no doors
so so
in sorry that my brain goes here but
this seems like as a young child
like
like is there anyone to protect you if
like you got you you got you do you see
these boundaries this is why you're so
scary this is why you're so this is why
we stare at you unblinkingly we're like
yeah
because i don't
oh hello
this is my real voice i just pretend to
be shrill and obnoxious when i'm
interviewing people
blue land imagine a land
that was blue
honestly i'm going to be very i'm going
to be straight forward about this blue
land thing
blue land
is a company that makes incredible
products to clean your home they are
fancy they are gorgeous they are
beautiful to look at they're actually
sexy am i allowed to say that this is a
sexy packaging it reduces waste it saves
the environment
i first heard about blue lamb when i was
listening to natasha legero's podcast
and i remember being like that's a
really good idea like i'm just trying to
clean my house why do i have to kill a
turtle blue land's idea is simple and
beautiful buy the bottle once refill it
forever no more plastic waste the only
thing you need to discard is your
outdated idea that eco-friendly products
are more expensive and less effective
look how sexy this is this is like to
put all the little um
uh dishwasher tablets it makes me feel
like someone with monogrammed towels i'm
really into this box all you do is put
your ashes in this so to just stay in
line with green you can even reuse the
these blue lamps
packaging as an urn it's so easy all you
do is put the tablet in the the bottle
you add water and bam you have a
cleaning product within minutes you have
a powerful cleaning product in the most
incredible scent such as iris agave
purine lemon and lavender eucalyptus
blue land's stunning high quality
forever bottles start at just ten
dollars when you buy a kit and are meant
to be reused forever with money saving
refill tablets that start at just two
dollars and i'm gonna read a text that
emily sent me earlier about blue land
which is i love this product so much do
they make douche
i wrote back no m
that's a real text that i got
20 off
your first order of any blue land
product at blueland.com
whitneyblueland.com
whitney that's 20 off your first order
of any blue land products at
blueland.com
whitney and not speaking of us modern
fertility
what it
[Music]
[Laughter]
means here we are
[Laughter]
here we are
motherless
[Music]
you're not motherless adam i'm right
here
speaking of mommies what if i told you
you could get important fertility inside
without ever going to the doctor or even
leaving your own home want to know if
you can bang out a bun that's why modern
fertility was created it's an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple finger
prick mail it in with a prepaid label
and you'll get your personalized results
within 10 days it's not theranose don't
panic you'll get insight into your
hormone levels your ovarian reserve aka
how many eggs you have compared to other
women your age who i bet i have more
than you and other important fertility
factors the results go deep into what
every hormone means and you can also
talk one-on-one with a fertility nurse
to review your results and options for
next steps a
friend so if you want to know uh if
you're fertile or just want to talk to
someone you need an excuse to talk to
someone modern fertility can help right
now modern fertility is offering our
listeners 20 off the test when you go to
modern
modernfertility.com
whitney that means your test will cost
139 instead of the hundreds or thousands
it could cost at a doctor's office get
20 dollars off your fertility test when
you go to
dot com modernfertility.com whitney
modern fertility.com
whitney march 18th i'm going to be in
portland
maine at the merrell auditorium
march 19th i'm going to be in laconia
new hampshire at the colonial
theater march 25th i'll be in new haven
connecticut at the college street music
hall march 26th i'm gonna be in albany
new york at the
egg april 1st i'm gonna be in austin
texas paramount theater april 2nd dallas
texas majestic theater um
oh my gosh why am i doing all this
april 3rd i'm doing seeing antonio with
the tobin center for performing arts may
20th tyson's corner this is the hometown
show capital one hall
june 26th i'll be in toronto and uh i
will stop boring you with all of this
and we'll get back to our guest that i'm
not interrupting the kind of like luxury
first world problems that we complain
about do you are you ever just like this
is so insane the kind of things that
this young spoiled country complains
about
given what you come from i get annoyed
with like the way people are about the
tiniest um things that they feel really
entitled to
the way people treat service people out
here is just atrocious disgusting like
they talk to the manager thing that
doesn't exist where we're from no
no you saw your problem right where you
are
yeah so is it so for the uh
a business in russia there's no like
hierarchy manager there's no like i
didn't get the service i wanted them to
complain
you got what you got
but there's no like
well you said the store would be open
until seven and it's 6 55 and i'm gonna
call your company or whatever
no one does that and is that that is
that just because it's it's rude or
unnecessary or is it because that uh
like because in america a lot of things
are franchises or corporations so i
think a lot of people can complain go oh
7-eleven i know that there's a higher-up
and this is a franchise that i can
complain to is it more because those are
family-owned businesses you would never
give a fuck about a slurpee god right
it's just not we don't complain about
shit like that it's just not important
yeah right there's the value system the
system's different yeah yeah right and
so and so you come to america what are
the main things you they're like this is
besides the living situation you just
move whenever you want like what are the
our medicines are also really different
and it's weird to come here and and
nothing is the same and the thing you
look for to treat yourself you guys
don't do what's up with the health care
system the health care like growing you
can't get well first of all my health
care just went up and smoked because
odessa was my health care like
their health care system is freaking
amazing and people don't understand no i
remember like a couple years ago you
went back to ukraine like for a
healthcare thing yes 100 when i can get
what i need here i go there dental there
and it's great and it's amazing and the
work is good it's like it's cheaper to
get a flight to ukraine 100 100 percent
it is full vacation yeah that's nuts
yeah it's about
for me it was like six thousand dollars
to go there stay separate from my family
go get all of my mris all of this ct
scans yeah see the best neurosurgeon who
flew in from jerusalem yesterday
all of that in the six thousand dollars
that it
and the tickets are like three so yeah
yeah wild that's that's right but like
growing up in russia growing up yeah
growing up like under communism like
this is
how
when you're sick
you have um a doctor come to your house
yeah and they come to your house for
free i'm sorry i'm being a dopey dope no
no this is what this podcast is for so
you're saying growing up in russia but i
thought you're from odessa but so
what i'm saying is like we use it
interchangeably you know i will i will
say though
it depends very much on the city okay
yes because odessa is a very it's a city
very russian very russian the more
international the city the more
likely the person is to identify as
russian because would it be like if
someone said someone that was born in
puerto rico was like are you puerto
rican or american right yes it's like
i'm both but technically yes it's a
personal preference it's like that and
it's also like she's saying
geographically specifically every every
city and every region is really
different like if you go and you talk to
people in kiev they're not
they don't sound the same like the
people because i guess the reason this
is like blowing my mind and maybe this
is part of yours too is that like now
that that russia is invading ukraine and
like
what you're uh uh what you are on some
level like right now identity if you're
moving out around the world you don't
want to be talk meeting someone be like
hey i'm russian you want to be like i'm
ukrainian because like i don't support
the shit that russia's doing right now
like is it something that's like sort of
changes based on poon's behavior yeah
and there's also just a lot of
adjustment for how you speak about
yourself based on the knowledge that
americans have which is very little so
when people would ask me when i first
moved here where i'm from i would say
odessa and they're like where is that
and i would say ukraine and they would
go huh right so then after that i'd be
like oh i'm russian and they understand
that sure sure so after you've been
doing that for so many years then people
are like wait you're actually ukrainian
why were you lying i'm like i'm not
lying find ukraine on a map
yeah you're too stupid so i didn't tell
you
it's you're dumb that's where i'm from
you're a fucking idiot
it's so annoying what would you say are
like the main misunderstandings about
russia ukraine just in general like the
dumbest questions you get oh my god
bears can i just can i just
they're there they're just playing beach
volleyball outside his house right i
mean the bear i must have gone so is
that a stereotype i i don't know if i've
heard this that there's a ton of bears
there yes there are there's a lot of
bears in west virginia but
sorry i've never maybe this is just
being a stupid westerner but i've never
thought of ukraine and russia is grouped
together i have really i never
but here's the thing but but but as
someone that in uh in high school what
you the they're such a cursory you get
like three days where you learn about
like the middle east you know eastern
europe eastern it's just sort of like it
doesn't matter it's not even we have a
negative perception it's like it this
this hugely
this country isn't even of the world
isn't even worth learning about uh to
the point to where it's like i've seen
it on a map i had to memorize ukraine
and russia and they were next to each
other and then
having to delineate like when they were
under the same rule in the soviets when
they weren't and then they fucking had
the gal to beat us in hockey and then
bay of pigs happened and then it was
just like fuck them and don't learn
about them but i see what you mean i
think if you're interested i was trying
to equate it to like what you were
saying with like the dc area someone
like where are you from i'm like
bethesda maryland they're like where's
that i'm like dc yeah so i just say dc
like in the same way but it's because
i've never i mean i'm not a very smart
geographic geography person but i've
never thought of russia and ukraine as
that's interchangeable i think that
you're you're also a worldly person and
i've met people that are ukrainian right
like so you know that they're different
on some level
i don't want to say average but the way
that we were taught was very much like
they're all it's all the same shit yes
all the same shit and it's not even
worth learning the difference i think
most people don't
think i'm so hungry they don't even know
i know no no
i think we should move on from this but
it's it's it's it's not even that people
don't know that they're separate it's
like i've never even spent enough time
to even think i'm sure they're separate
but like at one point they were block a
block
and then they were a union and now
they're separate but why are we even
talking about this who cares they beat
us in hockey and the guy that runs it's
an asshole yeah i'm saying i think it's
not even so much like we got the wrong
information it was like we just didn't
get any information you know how
impossible it is for us to even explain
where it is is i would say
confidently 98
of the people i've dated
still think i'm somewhere in russia
yeah because there's a rise i mean
putin's done an amazing job of making
you only everyone only kind of care
about russia
i'm saying and like his ascendancy has
always been like anyone around him is
going to be his at some point regardless
so why learn those other places around
it because he's just gonna take him back
at some point like i think it's just
more of a defeatist mentality like
but i i definitely think that the same
way maybe people that haven't learned a
lot about america
would think that like when i go to uh
outside of the states people are like
america all you americans are the same
kind of thing where you're like no
people in massachusetts are so different
than people in alabama but they're the
same country so it's like the kind of
thing where it's like even if ukraine
and russia are different it's all the
same shit the dolls and the language you
don't you know it's vodka like
i think we haven't learned the different
cultural nuances between them and what
they this is a great segue to my biggest
shock and that is that i wasn't in new
york and that's that's what i thought
america was new york was new york it's
more specifically
bruce willis and die hard that is what i
thought america was new york is mostly i
mean americans mostly fields and cows i
didn't come to l.a i came
to
we didn't know anybody when i came we
didn't know anybody in america we we had
no idea what we were doing
i just came with my mom and my stepdad
and the company that my stepdad that's
how we came over is the work visa the
company that my stepdad was working for
rented us the nicest place possibly that
i've still lived at um it was a town
house i didn't know what a town house
was but when i i saw this all the
distinctions for all of the house owning
very strange all of the condo and the
realtors and this is an escrow all of
that is
it's wild it's so crazy they have
multi-story houses here
what all of this is why and they're also
made of wood what like it's weird so the
people so let me ask you
growing up in russia
do people know that that exists
different kind of homes different ways
to move do they not know about it
because putin has made sure that no one
knows about it so to gaslight you into
thinking this is no we just never think
about it right
now but if you know if you find out
about it in russia are you like this is
it's like when i hear about what goes on
in scandinavia with like the healthcare
and i'm like what the fuck why don't we
have that like does it ever make people
they're mad or there's no point in even
thinking about how
they do a good job of just not making
you focus on the details i would say
yeah yeah it's like being mad at the sky
or something it's just always there
right and like but like the moving thing
that sofia was talking about was also
back in the soviet union yes right now
it's all modernized right now you can
have credit of course you know and stuff
like that what's credits um i mean like
you can take out credit oh credit yeah
you get credit right got it and then
okay and yeah and in terms of like
owning stuff and whatever all of that
became completely different after
communism fell but just to show you a
little bit about how people
have been socialized and grown up and
what the big
culture shock is yeah like
in childhood my biggest like pastime
that everybody had was literally
gathering by the swings
like we there's gathering by the swings
everybody in the entire yard did you yes
and we literally i mean
this is this is one say that word again
it's
it's you guys don't have this game but
it's a very long
i feel like when i was in those states
when i first came
they did somehow have it it's just a
long elastic and then
that girls people stand and then a girl
in the middle there's all these things
that you do to like with your leg to get
in and out of the elastics yeah it's
weird like we have like the jump
jump right like double double i don't
have that we don't have a double dutch
but we have that was also weird right i
was like huh huh but brizinko is like
what we did or like swings i was like
you play outside well you know the
difference is that to have an actual
functioning double dodge there's like
more pieces involved routine because
literally one piece of elastic this is
the whole
soviet mentality just one piece can we
just do something with just yeah yeah
yeah one string oh yeah like tetherball
i mean like it's like that that in
america i think it's not that that
swings and playing outside didn't exist
it just if you were poor right you know
what i'm saying like like like everyone
is sports right exactly
like we played with like uh uh on a tire
swing you know what i mean whereas if
you were rich you probably didn't have
that but it was sort of like so it's
like here just it it i think blows a lot
of people's minds that there's such a
giant country like russia that doesn't
have the opportunity to
elevate to a different class if you just
work hard enough or if you just you know
like you can't change your circumstances
regardless and you kind of surrender
that's that's like mind-blowing i think
to most like because we we move through
the world mostly on the pipe dream that
like if i just work hard enough i can
get out of this situation you know
whether it happens or not because of the
infrastructural failure and bullshit and
like uh the for profit education
it's a it it we're probably being gaslit
on sublevel because the upward mobility
is is in america is like a little bit of
a um fallacy but
that's what gets people through the day
the idea of i can get out of this
situation might just work hard enough
right but can i ask you about the news
i'm just cure so the last couple years
as americans were now like fake news
fake news the idea that a journalist
could have a bias or that something in
print could not be true is like
was like devastating to us as a country
even though there's always been
inherent bias with what you cover how
you cover it you know whatever
that's a different argument i'm just
curious your relationship to the news
growing up in a place where it's
is it fair to say mostly propaganda or
government run
um we still always
have people that tell the truth
it's it's always kind of a big part but
isn't there a fear that you're just
going to get poised to get killed all
the time
they got poisoned yeah yeah it's the
biggest head yeah but this is something
your female journalist that got shot in
the head in her apartment building when
was that
in the uh
actually yeah it's very very so so i
know you're to just i know this is
something that's totally normal but
that's like mind-blowing
i think the idea like just the idea that
it's like yeah if you tell the truth you
might just get poisoned at some point or
if you dare to challenge
you know
uh
uh putin's hubris like you could just
get shot in the head on the way to the
grocery store like before i came here i
specifically reached out to my friend in
moscow right now because everybody's
like why is it moscow protesting like
why aren't they doing anything and my
friend is literally like everybody's at
ikea trying to get their last chair
because everything is closing but more
importantly because right now they have
militia in the red square that americans
love like right by the cones there's
just militia and she said it's literally
illegal to smoke to stop to smoke you
have to keep walking as you're lighting
a cigarette and this is in russia right
now because they're concerned about
protests right they don't want anyone
coming they don't want anybody even
standing in the street you better you
got to keep moving if you're not moving
they'll come and push you so because the
protests that they did do got a lot of
media coverage and people were in so far
as to actually let like media take
pictures of their faces and print them
in newspapers which is like an
incredibly
brave and crazy thing to do
and i think that really shocked them
into being like oh fuck like we better
shut this down they're blanding colors
now too like yellow and blue are just
not in their rainbow anymore they're
policing children
yeah there's like six-year-olds being
detained and put they're just like
taking six-year-olds now so i mean
they're wearing ukrainian flag colors
like right or even just like like
holding up a little children drawn that
you can't even tell what it says but the
colors are there and they're like
holding up this little sign that
literally says peace it doesn't even say
anything it says peace and and they like
took them and then okay and i also just
want to say like a little tiny thing
that's heartbreaking because i tweeted
this and i just i can't keep i keep
thinking about it can you say your
twitter panel yeah it's the sofia
t-h-e-s-o-f-i-y-a
but um i tweeted this that the russian
word for peace and the russian word for
world is the same it's mir
so world peace is actually like just
world just world
which i think is incredibly beautiful
and it is very very sad to know
that civilians which in russian are
called mirnae peaceful people oh wow
are who's getting killed
and
um
seeing little kids
just writing mir right having that be
like they're not allowed to say
world they're like you imagine like like
the mountain sorry i just got like
chills yeah fuck yeah
yeah i i mean because my brain is
getting overwhelmed by all the things
that i want to ask and say and i and um
uh
but
if you say so you're a stand-up comedian
in the united states uh you're hilarious
you are uh uh you say shit that
cr that i'm that is brave that is
awesome that is
you know um
what if you want to be a comedian in uh
russia or a journalist in russia what
does that look like
artist in russia all of our artists are
the most i would say special people
right they're called uh you know um
right the voice of the people mm-hmm so
how do you how does that trajectory
happen well what it is is
there's always a secret coded thing
going on where like you can become a big
comedian and and your routines go viral
and everybody knows that you're talking
shit about the government like that can
still happen
but but
you can also lose
your entire life for that and you can
get murdered at any moment right they
can take stuff away from you and your
family you could lose money you can lose
jobs you can lose a lot of stuff yeah
but it doesn't mean that people still
don't do it right same with um our
musicians
i would say that
but the whole part of identity is that
there's a lot of loopholes like we're
the people of loopholes
and
like there's a ton of uh russian people
right now coming forward and they're
really people high up there who have a
lot to lose there are famous rock
musicians famous journalists uh rappers
trappers all of them they're all coming
forward but they all have a dual
citizenship well i was going to say
because from what i understand the
private airport uh teterboro in uh new
york is just full right now of russian
celebrities and oligarchs and actors and
stuff that are just flying to the states
right now none of yes they can all leave
they all have money they're all good
right and then so are you able to earn
money as a an artist over there without
that like can they just take money out
of your bank account if they want the
government
maybe putin i think can do pretty much
anything anything yeah he wants yeah but
i mean also like in the you know the
government sponsored art
because like russia very much
like part of the reason
the obsession with the olympics and all
of that stuff exists
really
is the russian view of themselves as
like
very intelligent and
um
sophisticated and very like
you know
the best art and the best books are
created by us that's kind of the view
yeah and like and yes we're the best
dancers and ballet dancers and the best
figures so he's supportive of art
because he wants to be the best and have
that crowd not that anybody actually
who's controlling the artists just don't
disagree with me don't embarrass me or
disagree we just want it to be a tool so
the greater that the art and the
achievement of the sports stars is the
greater putin is exactly his mind so to
him that is incredibly important right
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that that fucking figure skating thing
went so
bad explain it publicly
the girl that got caught doping well she
didn't do anything right she's a child
they all just fucking get kidnapped and
yeah trained but well it's kind of like
thought that the russian like the
russian team dopes and like there's
nothing anyone can do about it yeah if
you've ever seen the movie icarus like
doping's been part of it forever but
yeah so that's kind of the weird thing
about art it's like both
been state sponsored and had that has
helped artists have
money but it's also you're completely
tied and
i camila velliva will you explain what
happened can you explain what happened
sure valeeva was she's 15 just she's 15.
she's a baby yes she's a baby
everybody even the newscasters were
praising her like as she was going
through the olympics or like this is a
natural-born skater like we haven't seen
anything like this in in many many years
she was for everybody was confident like
she's gonna win
and then because she's doing a quad and
those are not thing quads women don't do
that's um but women have only really
done that is that four times right so
she was like revolution revolutionizing
and raising this level of being like oh
they women hadn't been able to do these
rotations and also combinations of them
yes and and so many of them in the
program she did like four or something
right like not just one but she just
kept going and going and going
and then right as the day was
approaching for them i believe for
singles
there's this news breaks out that she
tested positive for doping but not
while going to the olympics she test her
test came back that was like two almost
two months late it was like seven weeks
or something like two months late from
competing in a totally different
thing
and all of a sudden it just it was for
three heart treatment drugs which one is
banned as a performance enhancer by the
world anti-doping agency i mean they're
like heart treatment drugs but that's
kind of what lance armstrong was doing
it was like something that puts more
oxygen in your blood which people would
you know i mean it's not steroids or
adderall or whatever it's like a
recovery it's a recovery drug yeah i
mean that's kind of i don't know i'm on
her side but also
yeah it doesn't have that much to do i
mean she's also 15. she doesn't need to
dope it has nothing to do with her she's
been raised since she was a
tiny baby yeah to be the best figure
skater like every single person that is
on that one but even if she's doping and
doing all this it's still fucking good
everyone is doping like it's still
amazing yeah it's still unbelievable but
um and then can i growing up is there
like like when you're reading or
watching the news like are you taking it
with a grain of salt are you
you believe it is true and at what point
in your life do you learn like oh this
might like be this is a government-run
agency and like putin like the truth
that i'm getting
is biased
or controlled
like does that dawn on you at some point
to someone growing up in this
region
i would i would say that if you are
young
you have
a better understanding if you can work
an iphone mm-hmm yes you if you could
work in you know like you can
corroborate like your headlines or phone
if an iphone is something that you even
want to have you at least have access to
this kind of information but when you
guys were growing up it was probably a
little like the idea of like
yeah this was before
do you watch the news to get the truth
when you guys are growing up yeah you
still read the paper you still watch the
news what are you going to do right is
there a vibe of we want to change this
eventually or is like we just need putin
to die there was not this vibe
until
ukrainian government
uh yankovic
was on the precipice of joining the eu
and there were actually talks and the
year was about this uh i would
2010
it would have so the initial would have
been 2010 2011 okay and then
the talks and this is leading up to what
we call as a big thing maidan
which
so the people in power in the ukraine
were having this active talks about
ukraine joining the eu and this is where
things started to go wrong
what people need to know is
putin used to be
our
actual
boyfriend like to go back to that the
boyfriend with the credit card yeah
the pt cruiser right and this is
now all of a sudden you're like you have
this powerful friend yeah over there
who's like no actually i have a room in
my place you could move here yeah you
know and it's actually like i'm already
moving stuff out for you
um i just need the the go ahead like how
are you gonna pay for this like i'm
gonna need those credit cards um
and so what happened was the people were
like wait we do want the room like we we
want to go into the european union
and everything was leading up to it the
talks were happening
uh the european union though said you
know what though if you're going to move
here i don't i don't want to see his
face around here i don't want him
showing up at my house
and we have three things that needs to
happen the first thing was that you guys
need to get rid of this corruption he
can't be taking your money
sorry and you also can't be sponsoring
yourself like you gotta figure out that
codependent shit you got going on so no
corruption the second thing
i believe was um
[Music]
i mean i also had to do i actually
forget the second and third oh and then
the second thing that the eu didn't say
but ukraine kind of
pulled into it was the national identity
because they wanted to be there
to make more things separate like you
don't want to just be your
boyfriend's girlfriend you want to be
like you know i'm my own person
you know i'm going to have my own
language but is that a new thing for
people that grew up in russia that's
always been the american thing it is a
new thing purely because you have to
understand that
the russian language is so widespread
that it in schools let's let's take
schools and universities because that's
what that's
the important bit right everything was
taught in russian and so
when
this kind of idea of going more to the
west and away from russia influence
comes along peop
people were forced to switch over to
korean language and i think you and i
had previously talked about this because
i was telling you yeah that they had to
literally make up like a million words
in ukrainian that they didn't have in
the language before fascinating and this
is just blows people's minds because
this is like as someone that that that
is not signing up to solve this problem
who believes it's a problem that is like
the one tricky thing for for-profit
universities when you're like if it's if
it's run by the government who decides
what's taught right that's where you get
into this tricky thing where you're like
who decides what history was who decides
what books are taught who decides what
languages are taught you know that's
when you get into this like everything
is so much more fucking complicated
how does
he seems like he's very charming like i
watched putin's way this documentary on
him and i'm just obsessed with with
people that can get away with this kind
of thing like are they is their hiring
process that they're just picking people
that
didn't have a family that they know they
can
or that he just pays them so much money
that it's just worth it to them like
just does do people who grow up there
have an understanding of how he's able
to beguile and convince this many people
to carry this out it's not beguiling
it's either you're poor and scared and
that's how you're living or you have a
chance for a better life you have two
options go be ready shit yeah don't be
waiting for your family to be safe and
for them to go to a good school your
kids go to a good school you live in
actually a nice place and uh i don't
know you have a car which is crazy and
then you know you you eat really nice
food and you have a bathroom
like people are but also knowing that
at any given point
you can have like your you can just be
vaporized yes so it's like
like no matter what you do once you're
in it's over once you realize you made a
bad decision or doing something immoral
you can never get you're too far gone
it's mine you can never get out exactly
so so he's able to do all this just
simply because you it's like choose your
poison you have to you have two bad
options one either live and be poor or
be rich and participate in overreacting
right exactly and it's essentially like
um
the way to think the way that i think
about it is like
uh
shit i just lost it i'll come don't
worry come on don't go anywhere because
i there's some things i still wanna any
other you know so when you think about
russian mail order bride you know this
thing that is like
a punch line is part of that because
that's there's so few options
to make money like
that's well first i'm sorry i i remember
a way to get out of russia it's not just
one sentence all i was going to say was
yeah i feel like a good way to describe
the two options are you live loophole to
loophole
or you lea you you are a gambler right
that is gambling
your
everything to have a nice life yeah and
your morals and your ethics and all of
that so do you want to be the loophole
to loophole person uh-huh or do you want
to be this other person or you're the
person that's going to try to get out
and go to america or whatever but you
have to have or i was going to say or
the third option is you're just really
really smart
yes just and he protects you because
you're part of the if you're really
really smart you'll get out exactly
does that put you in like an existential
crisis i mean you're obviously in
america now but just the idea of like
anything i have can be taken at any
point or i don't know different right
how does that manifest itself like
just straight in terms of your goals
your dreams
i'm always halfway expecting shit to go
sideways
not in like a negative way but i'm like
if shit goes down like yep that's so
that's probably what's going to happen
mm-hmm right i'm very much in the moment
i think mostly thanks to horses that's
the only way that i know is like in this
moment what do i want you're constantly
hyper aware of exactly what you want in
any given moment because it's all you
got
is like your goals are very short
it's very it's very hard to actually
think in advance because growing up in
that kind of environment i don't
understand how people even think about
like these american women go out there
like i have five year goal and 10 year
old i'm like are you kidding me
like wait wait when i grew up you're
sitting next to my vision board from
when i was 20. right i'm like what are
these what is going on here what do you
mean like no it's like literally
tomorrow
the like your entire world could be
shifted you could be thrown into a
different country that's what happened
without knowing i don't know and we also
like our language and stuff reflects
that like we have sayings like if you
ask my family if you were ever like uh
like if you're like if i call my mom
today and i'm like hey do you want to do
something tomorrow or sunday and she'll
always say no no
yes you have to live to it i that's a
common saying if you're like can we make
plans you're like no we have to live
until before tomorrow
but that's by the way i mean i'm in a
program to learn to live one day at a
time so it's like 12-step programs well
all you have to do is grow up in a
communist regime you just innately get
it
also in
in in the communal in the community room
that i was living in i mean she had the
alcoholic we also had alcoholics but we
also had
a wild forest cat no
an actual wild forest cat this thing it
was like this the size of a maine coon
is this like our coyotes
yeah it's like it's like because there's
no laws right so it's like i mean
there's no laws i mean who's going to
enforce them what are you going to do so
there's no police force yeah you guys
have like animal control we're like okay
yeah all right just get a tiger if you
want like right like the colin's gonna
stop you it's
if it eats your face that's on you so
okay so say you get burgled or
you know you won't who do you have
you call your dobermans up yeah you have
chopsticks or said right germany germany
you mean you just have dogs there are
there are dog breeds in russia that are
outlawed in america yeah yeah yeah you
know so you have those guys yeah and
that's who is protecting your house so
everybody has to have a dog you have to
have something to protect your room
but then there's there's no like police
force
they're suit i mean they're the most
corrupt you don't fucking got it you you
just you don't you kidding me no is this
part of what you're doing when you have
women have to be so scary because who's
going to protect you except yourself no
exactly yeah so you could be getting
trying to like get raped on the street
and literally they'll just walk by
unless you start throwing money at them
it's like no really help me i have
something to give you it's true it's
true and our whole our whole way of
operating is like bribes right that's
how we grew up because like
you know technically all the services
are available to everyone that's what
communism technically is and then you go
to a place but okay
why would that person treat you better
than the person a million other people
they saw that day right so you come and
you bring a bottle of vodka or um you
bring a thing of chocolates or you bring
flowers or that's all people get jobs
yes yes you can't get a job unless you
have money to get a good job you have to
already have money that's kind of the
case in hollywood right right so but
yeah so you get it so you get it so it's
basically like a giant hollywood that's
a country hollywood yes except
everybody's also poor it's not even they
haven't it's just they have something to
get for something to offer uh if you
want someone to um to yeah to like
basically if you want the cops to give a
shit about you or to prosecute something
that happened to you you either have to
be
rich
or powerful right and hopefully both
and a smooth transition from an
interview to talk about
[Music]
athletic greens now here's the thing
about athletic greens athletic greens
is such a big part of my life i don't
know if i'm allowed to say all the
things that i believe it's done for me
like legally i'm not right
i started using athletic greens when a
very
famous
sportsman
talked about it to me in person like
four years ago i started using athletic
greens
uh
joke's on me you're not supposed to
snort it
you're supposed to mix it in water
but i
believe
that everyone that thinks i'm like on
drugs and like everyone's like thinks
i'm on adderall and stuff i just have
energy i have so much energy
and i start and it is no quinky dink
that instead it's from around the time
that i started using athletic greens huh
yeah because with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals whole
foods source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right ag-1 is a small micro-habit with
big benefits it's one thing you can do
every single day to take great care of
yourself it costs you less than three
dollars a day you're investing in your
health and it's cheaper than your cold
brew habit athletic greens has over
seven thousand five star reviews so you
don't need to listen to just us it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into the
flu in cold season it's just one scoop
in a cup of water every day that's it no
need for a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens has
given going to give you a free one year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel tracks with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com whitney again
that is athleticgreens.com whitney to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
best fiends
you all know about best fiends
it is a mobile
puzzle game that anyone can download and
play well they have a few minutes you
have a few hours best fiends is the
perfect puzzle game to lose yourself in
because you're having so much
fun
best fiends
you guys know
it's all we do around here quite frankly
pretty much the more you play the more
characters you collect see that's that's
what i like about it it's like um
well i guess that's i shouldn't talk
about scientology but if the more you do
it the more access you get do you know
what i'm saying
so like someone who's just starting like
doesn't that it's so perfect i'm just
saying i love that i like
a new person can't just come along and
have access to the same characters i
have something right i've earned it i've
been in the best fiends world longer
like you can't just come along and get
this slug there are thousands
there are thousands of public puzzles
thousands of levels what level are you
on i'm on level 300 not 300. my phone uh
sometimes i forget to charge it uh so
actually we've decided that grace tries
to keep your phone not charged that you
don't text her is that what it is i
think it might be but she's also
screwing with her best fiends levels so
now she's in big trouble
i don't know
i don't know the gaslighting is real
over here you guys new characters and
challenging puzzles are added all the
time and there are tons of fun events
where you can win huge rewards in game
download best fiends free today on the
app store or google play that's friends
without the r best fiends
back to our guest
who
i'm gonna have you ask questions because
i just i have to pee so bad i don't
wanna go pee i don't want to not be
focused but also these we have questions
from instagram that you guys said all
right let's start with
why is putin destroying the thing that
he wants
can we answer that that is a great
question
and the answer is that he didn't think
he would be destroying it god i didn't
think it would go down like this right
he thought like like this is the
this is the piece that blows people's
minds and it's so sad and true the some
of the soldiers in the tanks that are
going first of all not nobody knows
where they're going second of all the
soldiers in the tanks that are going to
ukraine are literally leaving the top
part of the tank open and coming out of
the tank because they think they're
being great alive
greeted by the people that are they're
like coming home but they didn't tell
them what they're going so
putin's idea was that
they could just take for some i mean
look the guy has lost it right he
thought that they would literally come
there's a lot of rumors that he's
mentally like
totally yeah so yeah one of the theories
i have or i'm not the only one there's
one of them is that he has like brain
cancer
and that it's i've heard that that it's
also like one of those things so most
brain cancers are fatal right so people
are like he's just gonna blow this whole
thing up he doesn't have anything to
lose and also it's affecting his
judgment i don't know because there's a
great thing no i mean that was the same
thing with trump when a lot of people
were saying that he had defensive
syphilis or like when you have syphilis
if you get it like in the if you've had
like 30 years that you're it
deteriorates your frontal lobe your
magdala doesn't operate i mean it's
legitimate there's a great article in
the atlantic also of i was hoping to
talk more about this but just in terms
of like
you know being in power for 20 years
like one thing america has you know did
figure out on some level even though a
lot is broken and the constitution was
written at a time that is just not does
not at all reflect reality today it's
got to be like we need a software update
on that but how power causes brain
damage
how leaders lose mental capacities most
notably for reading other people
some something that was essential to
their eyes and a lot of people that are
in this kind of power are sociopaths or
psychopaths and lack empathy in a way
that it's just like for him we're going
oh my god how can you invade this
country of 44 million people that had
their independence and like to him it's
just like i need to throw this bottle in
the trash you know what i mean like it's
it's
you know so that's just fascinating the
checks and balances of america there was
like some i mean it's such a young
country but something of like we cannot
let one person
just change the constitution right it's
not like it was in there being we're
like yeah you come in for 20 years we're
very aware of how we only really have
two settings for rulers like dictators
or dead dictators right we were we
weren't trying to have that go down
again but you can't control them once
they're there that's what's fucked about
it and then what the fuck is the kgb is
the kg because putin came from the kgb
secret it's russian secret is it our fbi
cia it's closer to like the secret
police
nazi style right so it's
government-funded or it's
government-funded correct and also he
served in germany during
you know
essentially with the nazis like very it
was still kind of
that idea that ideology over there when
he was in the kgb in germany when he
first started out and then he went into
politics directly from the kgb so all he
knows is literally that paranoia would
that be that's why i mean we knew
everything like you cannot like kgb is
like
right
what
it's you don't fuck with the kgb is that
like it is that the first thing it's
like if you found out that like a clan
member was running for off for for
president you'd be like but oh my god
they've done so much terrible stuff
during the cold war the kgb actively
sought to combat uh ideological
subversion anti-communist political and
religious ideas and the de the
dissidents who promoted them which was
generally dealt with so this is like
when you hear about people disappearing
right that's kgb this is a man that that
goes if you disagree with me you just
you go away and the id in in america
which is kind of you know which i think
the reason this is just important not
that we can solve this war right now
today obviously like
but
you know
at a time where as comedians
it's like
when people say
if you if you say the wrong pronoun for
someone i believe everyone should be
able to be called whatever they want to
be called and we should respect that you
know don't be a dick but if you get it
wrong then you're canceled and then you
go away forever and if you say you know
kevin hart at the oscars making a joke
about the gay doll house whatever i'm
not saying it's it's a fair joke i'm not
saying something's homophobic i'm not
putting a judgment on it but when we
spend a bunch of time
like voluntarily
saying people shouldn't be able to say
things or do things on twitter and then
you and you just go
oh my god i can't believe we're even in
a country where we can even have these
conversations
you know like we like we
we spend so much time complaining about
the um luxuries we have if that makes
any sense the biggest i think from what
you just said the biggest difference is
that right now in america it's people
policing policing people
yes we don't have that luxury because we
already have 20 other
government entities policing us just the
idea of free speech
like right now we're in a little bit of
a
you know whatever you want to call it
cancel culture pc war where it's like
don't say that don't say that it's just
like how lucky are we that we live in a
country where like
your feelings get hurt opposed to your
get murdered if you tell a joke against
the government right we don't talk about
feelings in either country no we don't
have feelings no
no what does that mean so there's
there's no therapy there's no therapy
no
i had to literally hide from my family
even though i had i was like so meant
i was i'm bipolar so i had to literally
hide getting treatment because my mom
was like don't do that
i'm like hi i want to die like i
literally i'm suicidal and she was like
well but the drugs are scary why don't
you do that right why would you go to
therapy like that's crazy so i'm like oh
okay i can't talk to you about this i
just have to not take care of it and
then she'll come around it may ask like
is that something that is
uh because there's no point in
entertaining it because we can't afford
treatment anyway or is it like you don't
show vulnerability it's a cultural
you're weak if you have any kind of flaw
or
uh
you know neurodiversity right well any
kind of diversity really yeah you know
it's having feelings wants and needs
like you're very much raised to be
self-contained yes
you can have ones everybody's expected
to have once you're weird if you don't
have wants
um
and and you're supposed to have judgment
it's a very a lot of judgment a lot of
judgment yeah that's for example this is
the right way this is right the wrong
way is how you behave this is how you do
not behave and shame on you yeah we're
much more strong like strongly like
attached to things like
i don't know uh
manners
yes and things that are like to us like
that is the way that we operate and that
is like the way
i would say weirdly in all of this
poverty the ideals that did stick with
the people are very much come from
russian aristocracy like like poets like
bohemian aristocracy this is why have to
be number one in ballet everybody has to
be it's about achievements and it's
about like if i i'm just going to use
language that's probably wrong but it's
like everyone's just sort of like a a
russian robot of like don't be needless
wantless achieve as much as possible
for a country for the country and your
behavior reflects
russia and like pull it together it's
not about you right yes right and this
is also like i think part of why ukraine
is succeeding right now because
i mean this is who you created people
putting together
to come to get put aside all of their
needs was we were taught to do this put
aside all your needs all your wants all
your aspirations didn't have those
that's fine um
just come fight that is what we're bred
to do do you look at americans as just
like brats yes
like 100 of the time but like i can't
like any time my husband's like
oh my god like you're gonna eat that raw
egg or some dumb shit like i know it's
oh my god has the chicken been out for
an extra hour i'm like what are you
fucking talking about no these things
are my worries whatsoever i'm like
salmonella what are you fucking talking
about americans are so like precious
just delicate so delicate so i'm gonna
uh throw out some questions from the
internet for y'all specifically
some of that what is propaganda and
what's not do you know do you care does
it even
matter like when you're growing up there
and then now as someone that's trying to
learn about this where do you go to even
learn about any of this
and it's stuff that was in american
history books was that all decided by
the history that stalin and lenin and
and now putin have
the information they've
i feel like this will probably
blow a lot of americans it rhymes
right
we don't care about you
i know it's going to come as a shot you
said it's so glad but they're always
like so like what did you guys think i'm
like
you are not a consideration wow so the
fact that you guys think so much about
us is always so weird to us why are you
so obsessed with me oh we're saying
like rent free all the time and then
learning english was that just something
that was that in school or just
something that you've watched i learned
it in school yeah and then how did you
what american tv shows or culture did
you consume growing up what was did you
have access to and what didn't you we
had um chip and dale but is this
something that because putin decides
what everybody gets to watch right chip
and dale tom and jerry that was the
american stuff we saw growing up i i
have more i mean i have a lot more love
for american tv because
uh it raised you it raised me yes you
know when i the only way to get me out
of bed when i was two or three was to
put on smells like teen spirit
um
nirvana song yes mtv my mom would put on
you to russian young girls that's like a
fun pop song it's about literally about
suicide listen this is this is like what
runs through my blood as a
three-year-old is all i wanted to hear
was that
that was it smells like teen spirit and
come as you are
those were my two yeah so nirvana was
like a fun that was band when i was
three that was a fun pop band to me
um
yes i mean by the time that you're five
you've already like had it i mean you've
had all the alcohol you wanted to have
and you've smoked everything you wanted
to smoke and then you know by the time
that you're 12
you're like discussing what condoms are
there drinking ages or no driving i
don't have that same experience they're
all i think i think you're more advanced
they're they're our drinking ages and
because you were you left
later yeah i was like there's drinking
ages there's drinking ages but they're
kind of like
i don't think anybody gives a fuck no
it's it's 18 but it's a joke and and you
can have alcohol anywhere like literally
in cars anywhere like
we don't have laws for no no alcohol is
anywhere but can i ask you a question
does that like
you know sort of the argument about
making drugs illegal is like when
something as a child is illegal you want
it more and then if you don't have it
until you're 18 then you're gonna while
that argument is 100 accurate nobody
drinks when you're like 15 i mean people
drink if you have access to it earlier
adults drink because life is really hard
right is drunk driving a problem kids
aren't like getting together and getting
trashed like the way american kids get
in high school and then like drive drunk
or whatever oh i was like what is wrong
with you people why are you drinking so
much you know when i turned 21 like
you're turning 21 i'm like i know i've
been drinking so i was like three
so what yeah why what's the big deal and
then they're like here drinking all the
time and when i go to visit my friends
in ukraine
we have like a glass of really good
champagne like civilized people nobody's
interested in it so there's the concept
of like alcoholism doesn't even kind of
alcohol yeah alcoholism exists but like
i said it is it is a a problem that i
don't think is a problem of oh people
are addicted to alcohol it's a problem
of uh this life is fucked up
anesthetizing and this is like and this
is what we have so we'll do that and and
and that's that's really how alcohol is
but when you're young it's not you're
not thinking of it as like oh i can't
wait to get drunk
that's not really the culture like when
i was because there's not a big
recreational culture anyway because the
way we drink here is when you go to the
homecoming dance or you're you know like
it's like right you do it
as a social lubricant but if you're not
socializing at these kind of so there's
a lack of like kids socializing in
parties and no that's socializing
but not like parties no kids socialize
outside yes but but there's not like
we're a concept of kids should be having
fun all the time we don't have have fun
yeah we don't i literally have a joke
about it
there's no expression like i'm like i
have you know i'm like
here in america when people um
when people say goodbye they're like um
all right have fun
and then i'm like well we don't have
that
my friend was like so what do you say
instead and i'm like uh
bye yeah
and then i was like oh wait you survived
but here's the thing then i'm like oh no
the other thing we say is uh um
good luck
right well that's yours
don't wear light blue or light yellow so
yeah so like essentially i'm like our
thing is like you know good luck hope
you survive today and don't get shot at
your nephew's christening good luck like
that's
that's the way we say goodbye with that
she like good luck out there well that
just gives you an idea of like this is
how hard life is see i this is fa this
is
it's just so
uh
important for lack of a better word um
i'm gonna use that basic bitch word um
so what are what are things in russia
that that just that you came to america
that just don't exist in russia i'm
going to be
clowns
because of clowns we love clowns okay
our bombs are actually amazing okay
because because i'm just saying what are
things that like do not exist there that
exist here whether it's emotions i
already established drinking laws
drinking laws
like
do you buy a car do you lease a car oh
there's no car transportation no no car
lisa public transportation public
transportation is amazing yes that's
amazing yes tramways trolley buses buses
right we have everything and if you yeah
of course i just mean if you're like if
you just want to
go to um uh on a vacation you can just
get a flight like is it like what are
they just the things that's not
different that's not different i think
but if you want to
move you'll have to get a visa like what
was your process in terms of uh becoming
an american citizen hers is different
from mine because
versus work visa copy workpiece is a lot
harder like i'm just trying to what i'm
getting to is the things that we take
for granted on a daily basis as
americans
with our sort of myopic
brattiness
i don't know that i can accurately speak
to the differences now
because it's so much later than when i
left but things were really hard you've
gone back since no okay my mom's been
back because i actually want to visit
russia but i guess planning a trip
before i guess it's kind of a weird
place to like spend your honeymoon
because people say it's incredible the
architecture's it's like being on a
different planet it's beautiful it's
stunning so where do you get your news
where if if someone wants to learn about
this follow this like educate themselves
about this because you know and i think
you know this i should have opened with
like why should we care like you know
there's so much stuff to care about
there's a lot of you know dark stuff
happening in
where in america there's problems here
right and
i think that when you go online or
you're like on a daily basis what am i
supposed to care about like how you know
i think we're all kind of in this
existential crisis like the way that
this from what i understand could
immediately affect us besides like if
you're a bleeding heart it's just
heartbreaking to know there's a war
going on you know i happen to have
friends that have family there and it
it's painful to like think about you
know you're when you told me you're you
know you have a grandmother in a nursing
home in ukraine like that's that makes
me not a nursing home but my i have
both of my grandmothers both of my
grandfathers in two separate
two separate buildings in different
parts of the city and but not both of
them have to stay exactly where they are
they basically just refused to go my mom
evacuated out on the fourth day of war
luckily um
my gran and it was very very hard for
her to leave my grandparents but my
grandparents have said
you know what my grandmother who is
very very she's very asian she's very
tough much tougher than i am if you can
imagine that um
this is this is a woman who had 70 she's
73 and she still teaches little kids how
to play tennis and they're winning yeah
and they're winning
and this is the woman who went she they
live on the first floor in little
crippled five-story buildings
which is
which has been there ever since soviet
union you know it's stitched together
but literally smen i have pictures of it
and they're still there and she said you
know what
i have a bait i have a basement it's not
a basement it's just like a little door
but the ball it's a little staircase
door right under your little patio that
people only build so that they can put
preserves in it because it backwards the
seller it's a seller yes thank you it's
a seller but like under the ground she
said i already went down to my cellar i
took out a bunch of jars and now i made
room between my tomatoes
and my cranberry jam and that is where
we're gonna go and that is it creamery
jam is the most russian shit i've ever
heard
uh but so so it's like i want what's
gonna happen you know what i'm saying so
so here's what could have like inflation
obviously you know
at the very least gas prices are
obviously gonna go up like stuff like
that like these sanctions are gonna
start coming in like how does this
affect
a normal
myself included all of us included
person on a daily basis gas prices will
of course go up we'll have problems in
the supply chain obviously like you know
a lot of people postulate that you know
like because america likes to be like
well we live in america and we're sort
of inoculated against anything that
happens in other countries like this is
a global system that when
it's a
uh
the domino effect will start um
happening and you know
there's there's a lot of people way
smarter than me that think that if this
continues that uh china will invade
taiwan and like we will
we might
be
like
people that are living in a
time where there's like world war three
you know like how what do you think is
gonna happen like are are we in our
lifetime do you think we're gonna have
like nuclear war
it seems that way it feels very real
like
i didn't think that this would ever
happen nobody ever thought this would
because i'm denying it i was just gonna
say that like even up until the moment
that the war started when you're like we
were like what's happening and like
emailing with our families and friends
and stuff no one thought it was going to
go down no my mother literally just did
the last second they're like no yeah
he's not going to invade that's crazy
because he because it's like first of
all it was like howard stern's point
about donald trump like why would you
want to run for president like at that
age it's such a hassle
like you can't really like cheat on your
wife anymore you can't live the life you
want to live like like
i think a lot of times we
are in denial about other people's crazy
behavior because we wouldn't want to do
it right and we project like my thing
with putin is to sort of like why would
you want to do this you're going to die
soon like you have billions of dollars
like why do you need this so badly like
my brain is like oh he's going to like
come to his senses and realize this is
just like
a fool's errand like
and to make it like really simple but
you're not dealing with a sane person
right it's also
like
why would a kgb guy go after a comedian
yeah
why does the kgb pick out a comedian
which is what what what is that
zielenski
president is a comedian yeah
you can do that right
he's like a sitcom star whitney yeah he
he played the president on a tv can you
imagine he played the president and then
he became the president
he and he's one of the most successful
comedians ever so you're already in this
bizarro like alternative alternative
reality
so is there a personal vendetta like
how much of this to you to knowing
what there is a personal of independence
how much of it feels like all it is is
personal that's all personal all it is
at the expense of a bunch of innocent
people exactly no one wants this war
putin is the only person that wants this
war and he's been manipulating the very
few people that are like you know we
would we do want to be russian or
whatever he's been manipulating and
stoking that anger to for his own like
he's butt hurt over something you guys
nothing too like he just i can't say
butthurt you cannot say i'm
hardline in the sand you cannot say
about her wait what's wrong with her i
did not know that it's very homophobic
butthurt
it's considered very homophobic now i
don't know where it is because i
literally did research on this like
a year ago
and
they were like no that's not where the
term comes from but her though now that
i'm thinking about it
it makes sense that it is but i did not
know that sorry so just re-say it well
cause i had originally i'm happy to make
the mistake in public because they're
sure but because i think the most people
didn't don't know that and i didn't know
that oh i thought that was no i'm glad
we're having this combo because all
three of us have completely different i
know the term butt hurt originally from
spanking the act of striking the buttock
i thought it was like i don't even know
what i thought it was frankly but i did
not think it was homophobic and as soon
as you said that i was like that tracks
bromance
is homophobic transphobic phrases to
stop using okay so butthurt let's unpack
this uh
we have so much other stuff i know i
know i know if but but i think for me
but i need to know this because i have
been walking around going like it feels
like putin's just butt hurt that he's
like you know so
if someone to know uh butthurt stems
from the act of an adult spanking a
child on the butt is a form of
punishment it hurts a form of control
and fear it also conjures up the idea of
anal sex and anal rape
to use the word butthurt as a way to
mock someone who is whining is also
mocking anal rape a very real risk for
queer men and transgender women rape is
not funny or clever what you don't say
thank you duckduckgo
and if not knowingly mocking anal rape
okay so yeah you're kind of mocking anal
rape if you say this is another this is
another thing of why americans should
care
uh yes homophobia is very much alive i
was gonna say russia russia i was more
than alive and well homophobia racism
what's up right so you can you can still
go to jail for being gay or
for speaking out about it in russia what
about ukraine no
wow
and and and another thing about that is
uh the the putin painting the picture
that you know oh i like actually i'm i'm
anti-nazi and like that's what i'm doing
by invading ukraine you're telling me
that kgb agent
right uh is gonna be
less
fucking uh
racist anti-semitic anything than the
guy who is i mean it just doesn't make
any but
it's 101. it's like when someone accuses
you of cheating
they're cheating it's like it's like
whatever you are accusing someone else
of a lot of times it's like your thing
it's like like when someone's like let
me see your phone you're like what okay
like what's going on with you that you
just went there you know so so but but
these types of personalities have
you know i'm just fascinated by by it
because it's something that has taken a
lot of you know
our lives as people just in personal
relationships and also just like
destroys the world is when it's
something called the big lie where
someone they they are so confident in a
big lie that they can gaslight people
into believing them just beca
uh uh um what's the example uh i lost my
train of thought
thank you for saying that earlier you
made me feel safe to be able to lose my
train of thought and now i'm doing it
and i manifested it oh the fact that he
goes it's the most thug shit to just in
a press conference people are like why
are you invading ukraine he's like
because the ukrainian government are a
bunch of drunks and uh drug addicts
drug addicts drug addicts
right they're a bunch of drug addicts
and i'm fighting nazis the person who's
doping the olympic yeah and when you
hear that
you're like oh yeah of course but it's
such a it's it's a lie that you would
like never get away with so the default
is like oh well it must be true because
they'd never get away with it so i
should believe it that mind fuck could a
drug addict lead a country during war
with literally no experience aside from
being a stand-up comedian
i don't know but also what's going on
with us we're on social media people are
like you know leader of ukraine kind of
a daddy it's like guys i know guys
i have to say
that is so annoying can we can we stop
the memification of like real shit well
that's that's where you get into a
situation where like okay on a daily
basis like what is your responsibility
as a human being on this planet where
it's like
memes about russia
like this is like saying as a comedian
i'm like everyone should be able to joke
about everything all the time but just
be conscious in
your
self-numbing of like if you're laughing
at memes about a war and like
just know that's you're frying your
brain
and not just that but like i feel like
when people do that they think like
we're offended that's why we're not on
board or something i'm like it's not
even that i'm not of no offended i just
don't understand i think it's just a
disservice to yourself as a person that
wants to be as a person that is trying
to stay conscious and not be a complete
zombie i'm trying to not like
fall into the trap of like oh
ukrainian's present is a daddy and look
at this meme of like just remember
ukrainians are judging you yeah
100 percent of the time
but like this i remember when there was
a video of
fidel castro like tripping and falling
and it is so funny to me but i remember
being like this is a
murderer yeah and like i this is just
like a funny like tom and jerry like
silly thing like the way that
that now
in the world we live in we're able to
like minimize things and and and
neuter things from their toxicity by
reducing them to like a meme or a gif or
whatever like what's the impact that is
going to have in terms of like a mass
desensitization
well it already happened right and
americans they feel like as a
this is a
stark difference
very not okay with bad emotions which is
weird to us because we're depressed all
the time and we're okay with that we
just own it it's like a state of being
and
you know you guys are over there like
running
to therapists which is amazing and
please keep doing that but we're not
there yet
we're okay with our negative emotions so
we don't really get the memes what is
your what have your pros what has your
process been since coming to america uh
learning about emotional vulnerability
like are you in therapy or do you feel
an inner monologue of like how dare you
feel sorry for yourself like do you
still have that inner monologue
that was programmed from how you were
raised i think i'm always gonna feel
like i'm two people i don't know if you
feel like that too like i feel like you
can tell that because i say our about
different countries so i'll be like oh
no we're like this and then it's like
well who's the weed and you'll be like
they're like then the next time i'll say
we and it'll be something else and i'm
like oh i'll always be this i'll always
be this weird hybrid where i'm gonna be
like oh
you don't understand
you know and i'll turn to her and i'll
know she'll exactly understand right do
you know what i'm saying what's the most
insulting thing someone can say about
like
like like you find yourself being able
to criticize
russia and putin but then is there ever
something that's like okay well now
that's just insulting like i find that
with america where it's like i'm the
first person to criticize but then
sometimes like okay but also
you can be gay and we have parades so
the times i do get protective and
defensive you know are kind of
interesting like it seems like all of
the
the
cultural commentators that's that trash
america are all from england i love john
oliver i'm a big fan but there was just
like this moment where i was like piers
morgan all these people were i'm like
then fucking go back there where you
don't have where you know like
like like i'll get protective in weird
places yeah it's like when someone makes
fun of your sister like you can talk as
much shit about your sister as you want
to if someone else talks about your
sister you're like fuck you yeah exactly
where is the line where it's like you're
like you're like these are my problems
and then you're like okay well also
i don't like it when people think
there's nothing positive the education
system is something that feels like
cable yeah yeah like the like the the
the fact that at least we can fucking
read bitch and do back yeah and then and
the thing about like the the like
communism doesn't work but capitalism is
so great i don't like that i'm not like
a communism stand but i'm also a realist
yeah it's just really annoying you're
able to say two things exist at once
yeah like communism is not it hasn't
worked great in the past and yeah
capitalism has some problems too
and i also don't like it when people
say say things about
the culture or the country without
having any understanding and like for
you to even explain to them how far off
they are you would have to go so far
back into yours like so you just kind of
get lost you're like all right i just
can't start it's too far how do you feel
like that sometimes all the time yeah
that's that's what i kind of said i was
like none of my boyfriends actually know
where i'm from because i'm like i'm not
about to teach you the entire geography
course that i've personally had before i
entered school right we have a really
strong sense of self right that's i
think one thing that is really different
about the way that we grow up out like
we elected a comedian to run our guys i
think americans like like their ideas
like you search for who you are you
search for who you are your whole life
and you're always like oh maybe i'm this
or maybe i'm this our
the way we are is more like you're born
who you are
i have to also put in there that i mean
i work with children once again and like
uh
the behaviorally the way that you are
raised i mean
i'm speaking for myself but also a lot
of other kids
most other kids have better childhoods
than i do um but
it pushes instead of raising you up
they're literally just beating you down
like the teacher in the school is like
first grade like you didn't do this
homework oh why because you're stupid
and you can't do anything
oh little timmy okay well if you don't
stand up to that teacher and you're like
oh my god you know what i mean like
either you don't care about what they
say like as a very long child either you
stop giving a shit about the entire
world
or
you become the victim and that's our
entire country is literally just
uh
in russia i know how to say it but how
do you say it in english it's like in
psychology in psychology it's like
policy
it's like um
the
execution i love this the executioner
and the victim yes yes yes
that's a psychological thing that under
pressure if you have a very strong
personality and a very strong sense of
self you become an executioner like how
do you respond and the stress doesn't
stop it just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger as you age and so then if you've
given up your position early on then you
become the victim and then you start
being the person and gets the red
diploma because you're just
working yourself you're like you're not
developing your identity you're
literally just trying to race against
you're like that race horse just like
i'm gonna kill myself right right right
right
you know you become this automaton of
like a victim or you become like what we
say which i don't like uh when when
horses you break a horse they call it
that because you break someone's spirit
i think part of the reason i get so
like is someone that
it does not have a degree in political
science and has no business talking
about stuff like this i think it it as
someone that
you know i'm a big animal rescue person
when and when something is voiceless or
powerless
if their circumstances and their spirit
breaks like it just
that is something that like
is um a big i'm trying to just not say
the word trigger or journey um
uh like you can say it no that's
something that just drives me nuts when
you're like oh this person is benefiting
by just breaking the spirit of so many
people and
to not be able to express your
individuality or your sexuality or your
whatever is like what's the point of
being alive if you're not able to
you know
say what you want to say or be silly you
know like it drives me nuts it's not
okay to express your individuality but
it is okay to express your aggression
that is
the fundamental difference between the
two
i mean i also feel like you know might
sound like we're just like so dark but
actually like we're the funniest
and it's
though too and like it's intelligence
and it's survival like the only way you
can survive is if you're like okay this
is kind of fucked and hilarious yeah so
we have a really really strong tradition
of that and like and by the way also in
judaism yes i mean
if you were we were talking about
identity before and you're like are you
russian are you ukrainian how do you
identify sorry if i'm being offensive oh
no no no not at all but what i was going
to say is like uh the identity that if
you ask anybody from odessa who they are
they'll say a deceit exactly we're like
our own we don't consider how weird yeah
yeah it's it's really like a very i like
i'm like it's a specific tribe like a
deceit is like its own thing so it's
it's
the identity thing comes
in so many different forms that it's
like almost impossible to answer but i
think that would fit us more than any of
the other words
that's fascinating and i know i have to
let you guys go but um i
i i would love to do this again no
pressure because there's more because i
want to talk also about you and your
comedy career and i want to talk to um
genevieve about um what she does in her
equine therapy and uh working with kids
and stuff so maybe we can do like a part
two oh yeah is that possible yeah and
because there's so many more questions
and i i think that you know it is just
our responsibility as people to
understand like the privilege that we
walk through the world with and like
just have perspective so if you if you
get to have perspective and you still
choose to be an asshole like that's
totally on you that's your choice but
you know most people just i think don't
have access to have conversations like
this with people like you that are so
you know
number one
have a bully like me to make you come
here and talk to me and ask all these
questions but then also
um
you know i think a lot of people aren't
willing to ask dumb questions because no
one wants to look stupid you know but
that's how you stay stupid so um i'd
love to do another round of just like
stupid questions to understand because i
think that america which
not that i'm
trying to
you know
like america's lives americans all
americans lives needs to be easier at
all times and that's my cause it's more
like america is a very important part of
america's hegemony a lot of good things
in the globe hinge on that let love it
or hate it you know the value system we
spend a lot of time criticizing america
which is a very american thing to be
able to criticize america and not get
shot it's a big part of our thing uh is
to say like our bed isn't soft enough
and our bed isn't organic and our bed is
you know has chemicals in it like we're
you know but
uh the values i think a lot of times we
throw the baby out with the bathwater in
terms of um
the value system upon which this this
country was created is
is incredible not perfect
of course flawed but i think
as a country we're starting to
deteriorate our ability to be a moral
leader because we're
self-flagellating to the point of
for losing perspective of how much
freedom and there actually is here and
the good side of being being able to
just get in a fight on twitter the fact
that you can even complain about not
being able to find an apartment in new
york because they're overpriced like the
things we complain about are still like
triumphs in the grand scheme of things
and i think it's hard to have that
perspective if you're stuck in your own
algorithm and you're stuck in your own
you know um like
bubble and so i just want to do more of
this um because i think it's very easy
to go like
that's a bunch of people in like fur
hats in boots
chasing bears
and that doesn't affect me it does
affect what happens over there does
affect us in a really real uh really big
way and if we're just sitting around
like laughing at memes about how hot the
ukrainian president is like we're just
participating in just
mass nihilism and our own i think
psychological deterioration also ukraine
has known this the whole time like we
kind of liked him
yeah so
we're okay with it like we wanted him in
office for you know a reason yeah yeah
yeah he's going to be all over tv may as
well yeah yeah well which is yeah that's
silvio berlusconi one-on-one too is you
know but um of being you know it would i
mean that's what we did with kennedy not
insanity was a bad president but it was
like he was the
one of the first presidents everybody
with a body
after the television came along and it
was like oh we can't have ugly
politicians anymore we have tvs now have
you seen the mayor of kiev i mean maybe
it's just my taste but he's a he's a
what's like justin trudeau when all
these people were like
ever since he invented the television
our politicians also have to be hot like
this is a weird curveball and then if
they're ugly all we do is make fun of
their appearance like trump i'm not
talking about him as a politician
anything but the fact that we only
talked about his hair it was just like
jokes on us because that's all we can
talk about because we're such
superficial visual weirdos um okay i
love you i'm gonna end this very
awkwardly and abruptly and not do
justice at all i love you guys don't
write elephants uh can you guys please
just say your instagram and twitter
handles again
sophie alexandra uh i am at the sophia
on twitter and instagram sophia spelled
s-o-f-i-y-a and your instagram is where
i get all my news about this situation
your tweets and uh uh instagram wow
thanks just oh and if you if you guys do
want to know resources key of
independent
great paper follow them uh
um there's also a bunch of he's like a
main reporter uh there's a ton of people
doing really good work if you wanna um
i'm actually gonna put together a little
resource nice and we'll post it
do you want to collab on that because
sure we we can read in russian and um
and ukrainian so we can
i was going to say my researchers are
all in russian say and i've been
listening to this i don't know is this
basic and embarrassing this bbc ukraine
cast
it's a podcast bbc is my source okay
it's it's european but it's neutral so
it's that's what it is
i trust the bbc it just is like a
podcast that just helps you not be a
complete idiot moving through the world
about this situation that feels like
it's not total drivel okay jen give us
your genevieve also if you want uh uh
for everyone that um
is inspired by our equine journey
jen
my personal instinct is sweet gla and my
horse insta is vive equine all one word
vive spelled v-i-e-v-e and then where
i'm always tagging her in my stories so
you'll be able to click and just find
her but we're gonna have to do this
again because there's just too much to
cover and uh i say one quick thing
anything sorry um i i forgot about this
but i wanted to mention it we were like
one of the things that what do you hate
the most so yeah
right now americans are getting really
gung-ho about ukrainian independence but
that also means that they're really
cheering on like the deaths of like
russian kids who did not want to be in
this war yeah they're like retweeting
like losses and being like fuck yeah
fuck you or like pictures of charred
bodies
um stop don't do that
don't do that they don't want to be
there they're someone's children don't
do that
they're sisters and brothers of us we
don't want you to blame them for the war
yeah they that's not them and don't
unnecessarily and maybe do you want
people posting the ukrainian flag on
twitter do you want people posting this
stuff for their own performative gain
like is that something that's like
is it help maybe it is helpful because
like maybe that's how we get our news
now like i mean some people might just
go like oh there's a war in ukraine i
didn't know about that even though it's
like a celebrity that's obviously just
trying to
like do the thing everybody's doing or
just like use a news piece to steam
compa who cares what the motives are or
maybe they really do care and they're
just too donut like i will i will say
this if you're a celebrity and you're
using the ukrainian flag at least donate
to at least one of the like unicef
donate
if you're gonna
use it donate to it if you do that great
awesome good for you i love what pornhub
did pornhub shut down born in russia
they didn't oh they didn't that was a
rumor it's not true
it's okay everything else is shut down
so i know no you can still jerk off in
russia sorry i just remember i just
remember thinking like like like okay
when i thought that was true i also
remember being like i feel like they're
going to be fine like i feel like putin
also most of the porn is made by us
right so i don't know what you're doing
i feel like putin could just like go
downstairs
and watch the hookers like
whatever he wants we love you guys thank
you
[Music]
six
[Applause]